[Music]
in thug life news dog Lord
my favorite meme submitted by DMD geek
margins in Dragon there you go
a mother explains why she pulled a gun
during a fight between teenage girls
because they were [ __ ] it strong
were they gangster chicks oh all right I
guess so this takes place in Houston and
could be cholos out there teenage girls
are pretty vicious too there's a 15 and
a 13 year old pretty vicious age 13 13
de Ridder Polynesian they could both be
over 200 pounds oh yeah
they can't I've seen them apparently the
the beef here started on snapchat there
was some sort of disagreement and then
it turned physical and then that's when
they one of the moms she stepped in and
I'll just show you the video here she
did explain an argument between
schoolmates ended with this Rumble over
the weekend in the video you can see two
teen girls fighting while a woman
appears to brandish a gun and threatened
people to get back I'm told this
actually started at another location
when Connie Washington and her family
showed up to a home senecio Barnes was
visiting to confront her Barnes mother
shot a locket told her to secure herself
inside and call the police when she
picked her up she took her to Washington
home to see what the fuss was about
that's where the story is told
differently she pulled the gun out on us
so we were fighting for our life we
couldn't do anything my niece was
basically not getting harmed by an adult
you know she's 15 the girl will start
seeing they're both teens they fight
they get into it
that's hot teens ooh but the mom she had
no reason to put her hands on her or
anything like that
Lockett says what she actually had was
her son's toy gun used only to scare
everyone away from her delivery gun she
also says a group of adults from
Washington's family came outside with
knives so she is the one who felt
threatened try to make me see my
favorite victim and I'm this
harsh person no I'm doing what a mother
should do which is protect a child and
y'all trying to make you see my guy and
do anything Wow look at that freeze see
serious do she means it
in Texas care enough a guy um okay so
the the kids fighting one of them's her
daughter right so she was using that gun
to scare away other people around them
so they won't come in and jump her so
she was claiming that the parents of the
other girl pulled out a knife and so she
went into her car pulled out the BB gun
to make them back off cuz she was she
saying she was scared for her cuz it
looked like she was telling people to
back off to let them let them work it
out fighting yeah she might stop the
fight she did go up to him afterwards
though there was a she walked up and
then the other girl was saying that the
mom was jumping in yeah there was this
one moment it's not in this video but in
this other video where she does kind of
like hit one of the girls you know what
they need to do is in every neighborhood
like there's a school park do you have
like a MMA cage and the kids can just
fight it out in there no octa with the
with the coat I mean you know like
referee and like the community can pay
for this oh yeah and we can solve our
issues gentlemanly or gentlewoman ly
this driveways are pretty dangerous yeah
but gives a safe environment to throw
down I think I'll be good yeah what if
some people are better with the legs
that's not in the ground they're better
on the ground we saw yeah yeah she's in
the ground and pound it's not fair for
wrestlers and the kickers because some
people just box better so we gotta
discriminate against them yeah yeah
we're wearing headgear
nope absolutely not no no and we'd have
to make sure that we weigh them and see
what the Reach's do you don't want it to
be they have to be fair mm-hmm
should be yep I mean we got a we got a
look at the two you know great role
models of the day ksi and Logan Paul you
know like they're getting pay-per-view
to make some people said to make money
and I say that's not their differences
to show a good example yeah YouTube beef
snapchat be the same thing yeah
and that's like a great example to show
you know what if y'all gonna fight go
make some make some money out of it yeah
do something today with one of you guys
now cuz I'm like you know we should work
it out yeah yeah and then we could get
popular make some money huh make some
money I wouldn't do it for the money I
would see we're doing this all wrong
guys every once a week we're sparring
we're fighting for free we're like we're
like you know low fell low self-esteem
hookers who you gonna win Logan I can't
sign oh you're gonna watch the fight I'm
watching for sure I think I am whose
house is that hosting this okay I'll go
to the opposite person's house for you
guys I want to watch this [ __ ] no that
[ __ ] this is all inner talking about
yeah what do you watch is so cool do i
watch Steve green videos i watch nicky
home good don't want that it's between
this and Mayweather professionals
professional fighters have you seen
local impulse bar though there's footage
he's good
looks pretty bad he looks pretty bad
what you're saying you good so you you
don't get entertained by watching
non-professional spike I do I love
videos you said you don't like street
fights but what about what about
professional caged or like like you said
it professionally no no they're in a
professional cage you said oh they're
putting them in a professional now
that's a waste of my time no no that's
dirt
it's a pay-per-view fight it's I know
but they're not professionals in
fighting so that's like just another
fight but just cleaned up but a knockout
the knockout it is yes I'm trying to see
knockouts are beautiful just update me
unlike what happens you don't want to
see how you fall I will say this if it's
not a knockout if it's just like they
both went the distance you gives people
should get the [ __ ] money back cuz it
was rigged I want them to slug hard yeah
you
no in ha whoever gets hit it's still
satisfying well I'm in them I'm in the
different camp than you guys cuz I like
Logan Paul I don't not like the Logan
point you worked with him I just think I
still do but there's a Jake there's a
Jake ball one to so we get double the
fun take from all starting to yeah
taking on what's the other dude's name
but his homie D good so it's like homie
versus home yeah I saw that you use
murder one of his tweet I think Logan's
gonna win okay over ksi I do why just
because he's uh way more athletic cuz he
works his ass off like he really really
[ __ ] work he's a lot bigger so I think
he's gonna win like easily but I've been
watching just from the footage I've seen
KS that looks better
alright not to no wires to fight sorry
girl you're on your own oh my god you
like me when I was like I'll never take
selfies likes no fees is [ __ ] it
guess what I lost that battle by [ __ ]
3 billion people taking selfies like
you're in that camp right now you're the
old man in the [ __ ] door it's not
entertaining to you to see the same
people in your industry to me exactly I
was a makeup person on YouTube and two
other makeup people about to throw down
that makes it it's so much more
entertaining though it's not like
convictive versus Manawatu or whatever
the goddamn UFC fights okay so the
reason why you don't want to watch it is
because it's not real so there's no real
beef and there's really there it's the
hope I feel okay fine but the hate is
real or there's an accidental punch like
if there's people getting hit is really
UFC fight where they get to do fight
however okay no no I think it's just a
lot there's pussy-ass boxers
it's a little [ __ ] compared to the UFC
I will say yeah how many rounds we
talking I don't know it might be three I
think that Jo Weller KS I was three just
three it's probably three because it's
an amateur fight now when I see 12
they're not gonna last 12 there's
they're not gonna last
damn but it was entertaining though the
the last Joel Weller case I fight I
liked it how do thank God I didn't watch
out we done was on paper it's literally
like watching a amateur fight it's the
same thing but then it has a legit
audience behind ya so you wouldn't
Christina Aguilera fight no you watch
him kiss though yeah so were you talking
about
no how did kiss they don't know how to
fight oh come on so you won't support
Bart if he has an amateur match because
you're saying he's not pearl enough he's
not good enough ah watch it you can't I
mean but it's bar of course I'm gonna
support it like this you're not a pro
when you guys are training out there I'm
like wow they really fall could suck
boots eike you would watch Britney and
Christina make out but they're not
professional make outers porn stars
[ __ ] with the professional is is
sucking dick to get their career that
professional I'm making out with each
other they're really gonna suck a dick
and covered balls to get their career up
the ladder but that's not what they're
doing in companies I didn't know that
you just educated me there for it I
don't want to watch him cuz anyway I
want to watch him suck dick we won't we
all what do you want I just wanted to
know is you just want you to come be
honest though so this what we're gonna
do all right for you guys okay I want
you to gather because all of my friends
are watching it I will watch it and then
we're gonna all update you on another
follow up just kidding his videos are
you doing it for a video now no I'm
doing it for my friends I said because
all of my friends are main reasons the
event on you know yeah you know she
denounced it in the video for a video
all right that's it you're you you
[ __ ] you see through me alright I
just I just want the numbers that's it
you guys are just nothing but a number
there it is
please do not destroy just kidding
no because I care by the way check out
the merch don't forget we don't even
have Mertz not so much there you go I
care so much that I want to see this
fight go down for real like I want to
see every youtuber fight like from this
point on even if these are dream fight
it
it's not even hey youtuber dream finally
I want to see a two-on-two with the
Merrill twins in the vlog brothers oh
well fine brothers how about fine
brothers final vlogmas is good ok ok ok
Steve so you supposedly worked with
Logan Paul yeah yeah yeah did work with
thanks guys I'll change cuz there's
legal like allegedly turn yeah well can
finish because it's not ok let me finish
alright thank you ah so you supposedly
worked with Logan Paul however I've
never seen him shout you out or you're
not even offering seats to like this
event so Logan Paul happens to be my
best friend so why aren't you going to
his fight bro why aren't you liking his
camp like in his room why he's gonna
warm up isn't it gonna be in the UK on
his tour like that he was doing JK news
do you even know him dude he's my best
friend
I have no better friend how much I have
to say this we'll see about that
so where are you watching the fight with
him or with us I'll be watching it live
behind his back dog
[Music]